am neujahrstag war die nasa sonde new
horizons am grüngürtel objekt ultima
thule vorbeigeflogen
seitdem folge stück für stück spannende
erkenntnisse über dieses äußerst
mysteriöse objekt beispielsweise ist
seine gestalt die zunächst an einen witz
abflachen stemann erinnert noch
außergewöhnlicher als vermutet doch das
ist noch längst nicht alles auf einer us
fachkonferenz wurden jetzt weitere
spannende detailkenntnisse veröffentlich
kriegs um science-fiction gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
ultima thule der wirklich mehr als
mysteriöse himmelskörper der sich im
kupfergürtel jenseits der umlaufbahn von
pluto und neptun befindet heißt
offiziell noch immer 2014 69 es 6,6
milliarden kilometer von der erde
entfernt und das ist der 44 fache
abstand von erde zur sonne die analyse
von ultima thule ist für die fachwelt
eine sensation weltpremiere
denn noch nie hat eine sonde ein objekt
untersucht das so weit entfernt ist und
auch wenn der vorbeiflug der nasa sonde
new horizons am ultima thule extrem
präzise war sind bislang nur wenige
aufgezeichnete bilder und messdaten zur
erde gelangt und wie werden wir wohl
noch bis zum herbst 2020 stückweise
immer mehr zu diesem himmelskörper
erfahren so lange wird wohl die
übertragung der daten dauernd jemand
ging es um science-fiction gibt's
natürlich immer direkt die neuesten
erkenntnisse bisher wissen wir über das
seltsam geformte himmelsobjekt dass es
rund 30 kilometer lang ist und aus zwei
körpern besteht auf den ersten blick
erinnert es an die form eines schneemann
es doch eine nase analyse konnte zeigen
dass ultima thule eben nicht aus zwei
kugeln besteht sondern dass größere
objekt ziemlich flach ist quasi so wie
ein pfannkuchen und schon die ersten
detail bilder zeigen dass die oberfläche
des objekts weitestgehend unversehrt
erscheinen vertiefung die an grad
erinnern und einen durchmesser von rund
100 meter namen wurden bisher nur ganz
wenige entdeckt vor allem am unteren
rand von ultima thule zeigen sich solche
kleinen einschränkungen doch sicher sind
sich die fachleute nicht ob es sich hier
tatsächlich um einschlagskrater handelt
denn diese einschränkungen könnten sich
auch durch andere prozesse geben
rätsel geben auch bisher noch die
länglichen rillen auf nach der vermutung
der fachleute könnten dies die grenzen
der ursprünglichen klumpen bilden die
sich dann irgendwann zu den beiden teil
körpern von ultima thule verschmolzen
haben nur reisen zeigt auch dass die
oberfläche von ultima thule auffällig
rot gefärbt ist spektralen analysen
zufolge liegt das daran dass sich dort
organische moleküle namens trine
ansammeln das bedeutet sowie schlammig
und bezeichnet ketten moleküle aus
kohlenstoff stickstoff und wasserstoff
wahrscheinlich bilden sich diese doline
durch den einfluss von uv strahlung
zudem entdeckte die nasa sonde auf
wassereis viele culpa gürtel bestehen
daraus so dass dies keine große
überraschung für die fachleute war
doch es gab eine andere große
überraschung und die haben experten und
expertinnen gerade auf der fachkonferenz
lunar and planetary science conference
in houston vorgestellt der new horizons
konnte auch festes methanol nachweisen
manchmal auch als holz alkohol bekannt
und das lässt selbst experten und
expertinnen staunen denn bisher konnte
festes methanol nur auf wirklich wenigen
himmelskörpern im äußeren sonnensystem
nachgewiesen werden es wird vermutet
dass es sich auf ultima thule aus wasser
und einfachen kohlenwasserstoffen
gebildet hat feststeht methanol ist für
uns menschen giftig ja sogar tödlich die
beteiligten wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler des new horizon teams
jedenfalls sind mit feuereifer bei der
sache so wie die forscherin silva proto
papa das spektrum von ultima thule
ähnelt einigen der extremsten objekte
die wir im äußeren sonnensystem gesehen
haben new horizons gibt uns also eine
unglaubliche gelegenheit einen dieser
körper aus der nähe zu studieren
raumstation in einem ausgehöhlten
asteroiden wort spinnerei oder
realistisch draufklicken und anschauen
ist mein tipp ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran